One solution to this problem of the scarcity of IP
addresses is Network Address Translation. This also helps mobile devices quickly
join and exit Local Area Networks, or LANs, as would happen
as you walk by a row of restaurants and coffee shops
with your phone. To be concrete and simple, let's suppose
that you have a combined modem/router connected to the internet in
your home. Now within your home, you can create a private
IP network using the network ID reserved for such a situation.
Specifically anything that starts with
192.168. Typically, the modem/router will allocate
IPs through a protocol called, Dynamic Host Configuration or DHCP. Let's
say that your computer gets the address 192.168.1.100, and your printer
gets 192.168.1.101. Your neighbor might also have a local area network with
a private IP address space, and maybe his printer and
computer get the same addresses. This turns out to be
okay. Remember that the network layer is dependent on the
link layer and everything ultimately get sent through the link
layer protocol. So, let's say that your computer knows the
IP address of the printer but not it's MAC address.
To find it the computer broadcasts an address resolution protocol
or ARP package to the whole linked network asking who
has the IP address 192.168.1.101. The printer will respond with
its MAC address and then we're good to go. Because
the ARP is sent by broadcast over the link layer
network, it never exits your private network in your home.
So there's no possibility of your pictures ending up on
your neighbor's printer or some such embarrassing circumstance. Of course,
you want to be able to do more than just
connect to other things around the house. You want to
be able to connect to cool web sites like Udacity.
let's connect your modem to your internet and give it the
IP 98.251.119.249. When you ask your computer to send a packet
to Udacity's IP, your computer will not find the matching IP
in it's routing table. So, it will send the packet to
the default gateway, in this case your router. The router will
also not find the IP in its table. It will really
only know about the private IPs. And so it will forward
the packet onto its default gateway on the wide area
network, the internet. As a parenthetical note here I should say
that packet is a term we use, the network layer, for
discrete chunks of data that get passed around. Eventually the packet
will reach the Udacity site. But it's not clear how
Udacity should send the information back. It can't use the local
IP address because there's no way to tell whether it should
send information to your computer or to your neighbor's. So instead,
your router actually swaps out your IP address for
its own. This way, Udacity can just swap the
source and IP addresses and then send that packet
back along with the data. The modem then just needs
to change the destination IP back to your computer,
and then route it along the private network in
your home. This is a little trickier, and involves
changing parts of the transport layer which we'll discuss later.